You'll be shocked at what you'll find in
rabbitic Judaism and their literature
regarding God. The God of Renic Judaism
has become so alien and foreign and
different,
right?
Different from the God of the Old
Testament. Rabbitic Judaism's God is not
the same.
You with me there? Let me qualify. What
do I mean? The gods of Tovia Singer and
Muhammad.
Number one, here is where I need you to
focus. Class begins. Let the spirit
teach to me. Number one,
rabbitic Judaism's God is not the God of
the Hebrew scriptures. Let me repeat,
the God of the Holy Bible, the God of
the Hebrew scriptures, the God revealed
in Jesus Christ, is not the God of
rabbitic Judaism. Rabbitic Judaism is a
hodgepodge
of gnosticism,
Hinduism,
neoplatinism.
It's a hodgepodge of a variety of
heresies
combined together
and repackaged as Old Testament
theology.
If you actually study Yeah. because the
influence of his Hinduism spread all
over the world. So I'm not saying that
the rabbis learned directly from
Hinduism. But in spreading all over the
world, interacting with other cultures,
these cultures that would have
interacted with India would have picked
up concepts and practices from the
Hindus that they would have incorporated
in their own paganism.
Okay? This is why in rabbitic Judaism
you find reincarnation.
Did you know that?
Reincarnation. Joel. In rabbitic Judaism
you have the belief of the
transmigration
of the soul. Reincarnation. Yep.
Zorastrianism.
It's a hodgepodge. Now I'm not saying no
group has been impacted affected by the
cultures around them, the views around
them, the religions and philosophies
around them. Even Christians
due to their interactions were impacted.
But because Jesus is real and he's Lord
and he sent the spirit, the spirit will
always make sure to guide Christians
and sanctify them in such a way where
these pagan corrupting elements would be
exposed by the spirit in order to
separate the truth from falsehood.
That's the work of the Holy Spirit in
the church. Yeah. You didn't know that?
Sam, I know it insults our Lord and
Mary. Please help me to help you. Please
stay focused. Stay focused.
Stop engaging one another, chiming in on
things you think are relevant. They're
not. Let the spirit teach through me.
Listen and learn. And may the Holy
Spirit save me from error and correct me
on the spot when I make a mistake. In
rabbitic Judaism, they have
reincarnation.
And in what they call mystical Judaism,
what they call the Cababala in their
book Zohar, Cababala, which is Jewish
mysticism, a hodgepodge of Hinduism,
Nosticism, they have the belief in what
they call the an excuse me for my
butchering of the Hebrew. An SF means
the infinite. And like the gnostic
heretics
that try to permeate and infilt in
infiltrate Christianity, but because the
Holy Spirit raised up the true servants
of God to expose narcissism and condemn
it like Araneus and others, Tertullian
in the Cababala, the a
has at least 10 emanations,
manifestations, 10 emanations that are
feminine and masculine, female and male.
manifestations emanations of the a
do you know that
everyone with me there
you can use sheh Google the greatest
rabbi ever lived and fact check me the
sof is the infinite
but from this infinite comes emanations
manifestations
there are at least 10 emanations
manifestations that are male and female.
Right? So there you have it. This is
Cababala, the book of Zohar. And in the
book of Zohar, it even interprets
Deuteronomy 6:4 as God having three
heads, three names, because there are
three. Did you know that
in the Zohar Jewish
book of mysticism
Zohar part of the Cababala there is a
commentary on Deuteronomy 6:4 and I'll
bring it up where they say the reason
why it says Jehovah our God Jehovah
three times because God is three-headed
threeheaded because there are three
right there are three that's why it's
three names. So here you have the
Cababala coming very close but not far
enough into affirming the triunityity of
God. But instead of a triunity it is
modalism emanations manifestations.
And if you know your nasticism,
whennosticism spread into Christianity
condemned by Paul and John and then the
later church fathers as an abomination,
a perversion of scripture, the Gnostics
believed in what they call the Plleoma
and the Aons. The Plleoma is the
fullness of the from the Plleoma came
emanations,
aons,
right? from the pl one aon and from that
one another aon and from that one
another aon so you see this gnostic
concept in Judaism and that the af has
10 manifestations emanations
that'snosticism
right in fact here Google it and get the
image you'll find it online here
so let me get you the image if I can and
then the tense Sephiot. Sephiot.
Everyone pronounce it. Here it is.
And I'll try to bring it up on my phone
if I can. Let's see. Come on, man. Let
it open up. One second.
The 10 sephido. See, I'm not lying, man.
Rebbit Judaism is from the pit of hell.
It's Luciferian.
It's Luciferian. It's not opening up. I
got to wait.
Yeah, Judaism is evil. Its evil rivals
that of Islam.
Now, I know some people won't agree with
me. Some are more sensitive. Here it is
on Wikipedia. You're going to see the
image, the tree, the tree of the aniote.
Click on it there. You'll see the tree.
I'm going to try to bring it up. I'm
going to try to bring it up on my phone
because I still don't know how to screen
share. All right.
Does this sound like biblical theology
or satanic luciferian perversion?
There you go. Let me open it up.
Here it is. Here's the tree. Do you see
it?
There's the tree. That's it right there.
See the 10 sephiro on the right and the
left.
Right.
See it?
That's what I just said. The infinite.
Oh, did you just uh Google it? Circle of
blessing confirm. Thank you, brother.
Fact check me because I can make a
mistake. There it goes. So, just put in
Sephiro and it's there.
This is rabbitic Judaism. This is the
God of Tovia Swinger. It's not the God
of the Bible.
You understand? Rabbitic Judaism is a
satanic perversion of biblical teaching.
They do not worship the God of the
Hebrew Bible anymore.
Right? And I'm going to show you Jesus
teaching that. Neither does Muhammad's
Allah. Muhammad's Allah is not the God
of the Bible. So if you're going to be
fair and consistent, you cannot say in
one breath, the God of Muhammad is a
false god, but the God of rabbitic
Judaism is your God. They're not.
Yep. Shakras and kundalini spirit
demonic. It all has the same source.
Satan perverting these religions to
deceive people away from the true God.
My my friend Joel.
What is Orthodox Judaism if not rabbitic
Judaism?
No. Orthodox Judaism is actually the
Orthodox Church. They call themselves
Orthodox Jews because they converted to
the Orthodox Church and they're
celebrating Easter this weekend.
Okay. Now,
let me get you what the Zor says. This
is Jewish mysticism, Cababala. So, I'm
not endorsing it. But even they see
Even they see
that Deuteronomy 6:4 points to a
trinity,
a convoluted trinity, nonetheless,
because they don't have the right
trinity. Okay, right here.
Okay, watch here. Let me get it for you.
I quote it in one of my articles. Okay,
let me get it for you guys. Deuteronomy.
Are you guys enjoying this thus far?
because I enjoy being used of the Holy
Spirit to serve you.
What better thing to do than to be with
brothers and sisters glorifying our God
and Savior, the Lord Jesus Christ.
Zohar. Let me get it for you guys. Oh my
goodness, I misspelled it. Darn it. I
hate when I misspelled it. See, this is
why I don't have a prepared speech. I
let the spirit guide me. Right.
Deuteronomy 6:4 Zohar.
But that's why. Can I Can I learn how to
spell Tippy Bear? Deuteronomy. I can't
even spell dudo.
Yeah. Deuteronomy.
Let's go here.
Zohar. Here's one of my articles where I
quote the Zohar.
Okay. Here you go. Here you go. This is
an article that I updated, I believe,
from Jews
for Jesus. So what I try to do is I find
articles and I update them or upload
them I should say not update them upload
them in case the website disappears. So
in this article right here, this is an
article I believe I took from Jews for
Jesus. Here it is what the Zohar says.
You ready? Quote. Let me give you the
quote. You ready?
Here it is. Read with me as I get you
the quote. This is from the article that
I uploaded.
The Zohar, the foundation book of Jewish
mysticism, recognize that the idea of a
plurality unity is not foreign to Jewish
thinking. While the medieval mystics
idea is different from the Christian
idea of the trinity, the basic idea of a
plurality within the one God still
holds. Now, it quotes from the Zohar.
The passage from the Zohar commenting on
the Shimma that 6:4 reads as follows.
So save that article and here's the
quote. All right, here's the quote.
A citation from Zohar, which is not a
trinitarian book
here. O Israel, Yahweh, Elohu, Yahweh is
one. Now watch, look at their
interpretation.
These three are one. How can the three
names be one?
Only through the perception of faith in
the vision of the Holy Spirit. So you
got to have a higher learning like the
Gnostics, nosis, illumination, then
you'll perceive in the vision of the
Holy Spirit. Watch here in the beholding
of the hidden eyes alone. The mystery of
the audible voice is similar to this.
For though it is one, yet it consists of
three elements: fire, air, and water,
which have however become one in the
mystery of the voice. Even so, it is the
mystery of the threefold divine
manifestations
designated by Yahweh Elohu Yahweh three
modes which yet form one unity. You see
there it goes.
You caught it.
Focus, brethren. Don't get distracted.
It's from this article and I quote it
elsewhere in another article that I
believe was also an upload. Yep. This is
from Jews for Jesus. It was published on
April 2028 and I uploaded it. Did you
see that quote?
So, it's not trinitarianism per se. It
is a form of modalism. It's a form of
modalism where the three manifestations
are eternal. Unlike the modalist today
where the modes change. So at one time
it's the father, another time the father
takes the mode of the son, another time
he appears in the mode of the spirit.
Here it's three eternal modes, three
eternal manifestations. So it's not
trinity per se because we don't believe
the father and holy spirit are three
modes manifestations. There are three
eternally distinct inseparable intimate
relationships.